let's speak to sylvia spake now who was
diagnosed with alzheimer's four years
ago
and her daughter tanya ord also joining
us is professor paul morgan
of the dementia research institute at
cardiff
university hello to all of you thank you
very much indeed for being with us
at sylvia four years since your
diagnosis what what led to it
what happened what led to your diagnosis
well i knew that i knew that uh my
memory
wasn't as good as it had been and i
weren't coping exactly the same because
i were employed as a nurse
at the hospital and i realized that
i might make a mistake so i left and and
that's what
got me really thinking about having a
diagnosis
and when you get a diagnosis of
alzheimer's sylvia
what does it mean at the moment in terms
of treatment was there anything
that could be done
i can't really remember the names of the
products that
uh the treatment how we're receiving but
my daughter can probably remember
my mum's on a medication for alzheimer's
that hopefully stops the progression of
it
um and i believe that it has has worked
for my mum to a certain extent
really and if this new drug
could be approved that could slow down
the onset of the condition
could could treat the causes rather than
the symptoms
what would that mean to both of you
it would mean a lot of independence from
a mum and other people who've got
alzheimer's
to be able to live an independent life
much longer than
possibly my mum and other people have um
because a big thing with alzheimer's is
that their independence is taken away
from them
and that's one of the main problems um
for the
the person who's got it and the issues
that they're suffering and how it
affects them
mentally as well because they don't want
to be dependent on other people
yeah and sylvia you do still live in
your own home but as you described you
had to give up your job
because of this yes i did but i weren't
uh asked to do it by
you know the authorities i did it
because i just wanted to be sure that i
weren't going to do any damage to
anybody
what's been the hardest thing for you
since your diagnosis
it's not feeling really good
and it has changed my life as far as
friendships and things like that and
going out and
going on holiday with friends and
um i think when you've got dementia
people step back because they're they're
more afraid of it than what you are
yeah so they're
which is really sad to hear and what
about your own confidence
in your ability to to do those things
um i think i'm quite confident i
i think i mean i could go on bragging
about myself but
i'll ask you you're very welcome how
about you get your daughter to do the
bragging for you
my mum is really confident and she's
she's quite an upbeat type of person
anyway
so she doesn't particularly get um
anxious about the condition she's a very
positive person
and i think that's helped my mum quite a
lot
um but there has been days when it has
upset her
because she knows things are changing
and things are deteriorating and she
can't quite
work things out quite as easily as what
she could and needs
prompted so that has had an effect on
her well your positivity
really does shine through sylvia let me
just bring in uh professor paul morgan
here
to give us a little bit more about the
potential of
this new drug there are very few
treatments and
no new drugs for almost two decades i
believe how significant a step forward
could this be
really sorry i've got a phone call keeps
coming through as you were talking then
i only caught part of what you said
could you repeat the question
yes i was just asking how significant a
step forward this new drug could be
for the treatment of alzheimer's
well i think it's it's unfortunate that
i have to say that we don't really
know this has been a very controversial
drug it's been around in development and
in
trials for a few years now and its
successes have been very limited um as
you probably know the
the fda rejected this drug just a few
months ago and then
decided to re-review it a few months
later which is
today that the results of that re-review
will come out
and many of the people who are on the
panels looking at the evidence that this
drug was
worthy of distributing getting available
for the public were very reluctant to
approve it indeed
because i think although as you say it
treats one of the potential causes for
alzheimer's disease
we don't know that it is actually
addressing the main cause of the disease
because we don't understand what the
main course of the
cause of the of the diseases in
alzheimer's patients
and particularly early on in the disease
when we really need to be treating
patients to prevent the decline
that is otherwise inevitable in patients
with this this terrible disease
given the numbers of people who are it's
a very small step
i'm sorry yes sorry professor we've got
a slight delay on the line
given that the sheer numbers of people
that are affected by this devastating
disease
why is it that we've had no new drugs
for the past two decades
well i think it's because we don't
understand the the the basic biology of
the disease
we have made huge progress over the last
10 years or so
and that's really come out of
understanding better what the genetics
of the disease are how
how our genes predispose us to getting
this disease
my own work is on the rules of the
inflammatory system what causes diseases
like rheumatoid arthritis have in
driving this disease
and i think we're still a little way
away from
understanding how this disease gets
initiated and what actually causes this
progressive decline in brain function
that we see in these patients
so although this drug which targets one
bit of the disease process called
amyloid and seems to be effective
at uh reducing the amount of amyloid in
the brain
looks promising and has potentially in
some of the studies some effect on the
progression
of the uh the loss of function the loss
of
cognition in in patients it is not
i think the game changer that has been
implied
and of course it comes at huge cost so
this if it were approved would cost
about fifty thousand dollars per
patient per year and for a disease which
is hugely common
like alzheimer's disease in the western
world that cost may not be affordable so
again it may be false promise for some
people because
in most countries even developed
countries that cost is just not
something that can be managed
by health services and if it does get
approval
in the united states as you describe it
it has been a controversial drug but if
it does get approved by
the fda what does that mean for here in
the uk
well it's a step towards it getting
approved elsewhere so
i think the fda set a precedent it will
then be looked at the
authority look looked at by the
authorities in
europe um and and in
the uk and those authorities will have
to assess the evidence themselves and
see if it meets their
high standards of evidence that this is
actually going to do some good because i
think to raise false hope
is is worse than anything it it's
it's a drug which in a re-analysis a
very large trial showed some effect it's
not a clear cut
result at all so i think we have to take
this with
some caution if it does get approved by
the fda today then it will go into i'm
sure
a lot more people in the states and then
in a few years time we have might have
much better evidence
as to whether it's actually effective or
not but at the moment i think caution
has to be the
the key word here this isn't the
game-changer this isn't the breakthrough
that we really need in this in this
field desperately
um let me get a final thought then
sylvia from from you and and tanya
listening to what professor morgan has
said there
that although it's progress this isn't
the game changer that
that we're looking for
i'm sorry you were breaking up bill a
little bit i'm sorry i was just gonna
get your reflections on what you've
heard from professor morgan there tanya
and
you sylvia listening to what he said
that that we can't give false hope that
this
isn't a game changer right now
right my opinion is that
at the moment i'm not personally i'm not
one duly concerned about it or even
trying something else
i feel i'm doing fine i'm coping well
i obviously have the off days where
everybody does with
conditions they have so
it's not a big concern to me i'm happy
as i am yeah the
the medication i i totally agree with
him that
there's got to be caution in place um
like with any other trials
with drugs but fingers crossed let's
hope that
um that is successful because it would
mean so much to people to
families yeah yeah um it's been
absolutely fantastic
speaking to you thank you very much
indeed
sylvia and tanya and also to professor
paul
morgan as well thank you thank you